ahora
las iglesias y las mezquitas de beirut
han sonado hoy a las 6 y 8 minutos justo
cuando hacía un mes desde la explosión
más grande en la historia del líbano
este gesto ha marcado el inicio de un
minuto de silencio y de las
conmemoraciones que víctimas familiares
y otras personas han querido celebrar
durante el día de hoy la concentración
más grande se ha dado en frente del
puerto de beirut donde centenares de
personas han cargado con velas nombres y
fotografías de sus seres queridos
también cargaban con sogas en
representación a su deseo de castigo
contra la clase política a la que ven
como culpable por negligencia el mensaje
de la protesta era bien claro no
olvidamos quiénes son los culpables de
lo ocurrido y no les perdonamos la
unidad entre los afectados por la
explosión contrasta con el abandona
miento por parte del estado los
dirigentes libaneses conocían la
presencia de los explosivos en el puerto
de virus pero un mes después no han
emitido disculpas ni tampoco han
colaborado con la recuperación de la
ciudad equipos de rescate y voluntarios
venidos desde todo el mundo siguen
trabajando codo con codo con la
población local para encontrar las
docenas de personas que siguen
pero admiten que encontrar cuerpos con
vida es prácticamente imposible